public sénat
[Musique]
bonjour à tous est ravie de vous
retrouver pour ce nouveau numéro de
parlement hebdo l'émission qui revient
sur les temps forts de l'actualité au
parlement et au sénat est avec moi pour
présenter cette émission elle tentera
nuit bonjour ta main bonjour brigitte
bonjour laurence rossignol vous n'êtes
vous êtes notre invité aujourd'hui et on
va voir votre parcours politique en
quelques mots et vous avez passé des
rangs de la lcr de l'espoir du grand
soir au parti socialiste en 1981
conquête par les urnes et gauche de
gouvernement vous avez d'ailleurs été
ministre des famille de l'enfance et des
droits des femmes sous le quinquennat de
françois hollande
votre signe distinctif le féminisme
chevillée au corps et les constitutifs
de votre engagement politique puisque
vous avez vous avez d'ailleurs fait
partie des pétroleuses du mlf le
mouvement de libération des femmes
pendant le confinement duo qu'ovide vous
avez beaucoup dénoncé la fragilisation
de l'accès ali vg pendant cette période
laurence rossignol autres victimes
possibles du colis de la loi de
bioéthique et sa mesure phare la pma
pour toutes
gilles legendre le patron des députés de
la république en marche espère pouvoir
adopter le texte d'ici la fin du
quinquennat
ça vous inquiète vous n'avez parquet
sont un petit peu enterrés ce texte pays
quand un président de groupe dit que il
espère pouvoir adopter le texte avant la
fin du quinquennat on n'entend qu'eux il
craint de ne pas pouvoir l'adopter ou le
salut est peut-être aussi indifférent de
ne pas pouvoir adopter je ne sais pas en
tous les cas une alerte dans son propos
est en fait on est là sur cette affaire
de loi bioéthique sur quelque chose qui
dès le départ a été mal engagée il
n'était pas utile de mettre la pma pour
toutes dans la loi bioéthique
ce n'est pas un problème de bioéthique
la progression la procréation
médicalement assistée est déjà une
technique dont on cote dont on connaît
beaucoup de choses et qu'on a déjà pu
évaluer sur le plan éthique
après la décision de l'ouvrir aux
couples de femmes ou femme seule est une
décision politique et non pas une
décision de bioéthique donc le
gouvernement a enfoui dirais-je la pma
pour toutes dans la loi de bioéthique
on sait qu un process de web bioéthique
est très long parce que on a beaucoup de
sujets il ya deux inconvénient à ça le
premier c'est que la pma pour tout n'est
toujours pas votée
le deuxième c'est qu'elle ait beaucoup
de sujets très importants dans la
bioéthique cherche de recherche sur
l'embryon
une série de choses très importantes qui
du coup n'ont pas n'ont pas franchi la
barre médiatique qu'un pas été jusqu'au
grand public parce que la pma pour tout
à cacher tout reste à phagocyter tout le
reste et on est là avec nine wabo
éthique ni la loi pma pour tous mais on
est dans une crise épidémique sans
précédent est ce que c'est vraiment
l'urgence de faire cette loi bioéthique
peut pas dire que soit l'urgence de
faire un bon outil clé ce qui était
apparemment une urgence quand même
c'était celle des femmes qui demandaient
que la pma pour tout soit voté de façon
à ce qu'elles cessent de se rendre à
l'étranger pour faire une pma donc c'est
un engagement du président de la
république dans sa campagne de 2017 et
je vois qu'il y avait des urgences dans
ses engagements de campagne qui était
pour lui et pour cette majorité en
marche plus important que la pma pour
tout donc on peut être inquiet à cette
étape et on aimerait bien que le
gouvernement nous donne un calendrier
mais franchement s'il n'y arrive pas à
faire voter la loi bioéthique qui
sortent la pma la loi de bioéthique qui
fasse un projet de loi avec urgence
comme ils le savent très bien le faire
pour des tas de sujets et convoque la
pma rapidement un arc deux articles et
c'est bon et on va revenir d'ailleurs
sur le fonctionnement du parlement voici
les titres de cette émission feu vert du
parlement à l'application stop qu'ovide
l'application controversée de traçage
numérique qui doit permettre de freiner
la propagation du virus
elle sera disponible à partir du 2 juin
ils portent diverses dispositions
urgentes le projet de loi fourre tout a
été passé par le sénat à la moulinette
et en sort expurgée de la moitié de ces
ordonnances des dons de congés ou des
rtt à convertir en chèques vacances
voilà la proposition de loi défendue par
le député et christophe blanche est
adoptée en commission elle sera débattue
mardi dans l'hémicycle de l'assemblée
et pour commencer cette émission le feu
vert du parlement à l'application
stop&go vide
[Musique]
débat sous tension à l'assemblée
nationale opposition plus feutrée au
sénat où la droite majoritaire a soutenu
le gouvernement stoppe qu'ovide fait
débat outils de sécurité sanitaire pour
les uns atteinte aux libertés pour les
autres résumé des discussions par marie
brémaud devant les parlementaires de
l'assemblée ou du sénat
même discours de la part de l'exécutif
qui après avoir revu sa copie plusieurs
fois présentait son projet de loi de
l'application de traçage stop qu'ovide
le téléchargement de cette application
de cette installation et résulte d'une
démarche volontaire de l'utilisateur
son installation est libre et gratuite
toutes les fonctionnalités ne pourront
être activés que si l'utilisateur le
souhaite et la désinstallation est
possible à tout moment
un discours qui se veut rassurant la
garde des sceaux récusant tout pistage
où tout fichage des français
mais à l'assemblée nationale où le
gouvernement dispose pourtant d'une
majorité confortable
l'opposition a été vigoureuse les
échanges nourris et tendue à l'image de
jean luc mélenchon qui s'inquiète d'une
société sous surveillance généralisée
après avoir jugulé en danger le virus
que 8,19 on pourrait en juguler d'autre
part une connaissance mutuelle plus
approfondie chers collègues avez vous vu
la tuberculose
mon téléphone me le dira etes-vous
mauvais payeur au moment où vous
rentrerez dans le magasin le téléphone
dira cet homme est déjà dans le rouge
ne lui donnez plus rien etc etc etc à
droite on profite de cette tribune pour
dénoncer la politique gouvernementale en
matière de santé ne faisons pas croire
aux français que cette application sera
l'alpha et l'oméga de la lutte contre le
coc vide ce sont les soignants qui sauve
les vies
ce sont les masques dont nous avons tant
manqué qui sauve les vies
ce sont les tests qui ont fait si
cruellement défaut pendant confinement
qui sauve les vies
vous avez préféré agité un écran de
fumée avec cette application pour mieux
masquer vos propres fautes défaillance
échos bond de salles deux ambiances et
l'illustration d'un désaccord au sein de
la famille des républicains
le patron dlr au sénat se rallient
derrière le projet du gouvernement
au nom de la lutte contre la pandémie le
traçage est essentiel parce que
lorsqu'une personne tombe malade il est
fondamental de pouvoir retrouver pour
les alerter
celles et ceux qu'elle a pu croiser et
possiblement évidemment contaminés c'est
absolument essentiel un texte finalement
adopté par le sénat mais aussi par
l'assemblée l'application sera déployé
en début de semaine prochaine
elle rentre signal votre groupe au sénat
a unanimement voté contre
pourquoi et peut-être on vient tout
petit peu en arrière sur la loi
d'urgence 2 dans laquelle le
gouvernement nous a proposé la mise en
place d'un système de recueil des
données confiées à l'assurance-maladie
du jour du fichier l'inconscient d'un
fichier on a compris comment ça se passe
quand une personne va chez le médecin le
médecin diagnostique une accolade à ce
moment là le médecin on voit officier à
l'assurance maladie
les quotas là les corps de sept
personnes la personne est ensuite
contacté et elle informe la laine son
interlocuteur des personnes qu'elle a
rencontrées pendant la période
d'incubation ce après quoi les la
brigade de l'assurance maladie
contact les personnes qui ont été en
contact avec la personne malade au
moment où on a voté cette ce fichier là
on a eu déjà un gros débat sur la
question des libertés de la mise en
place d'un fichier de sa durée de vie
mais vous l'avez voter encore ça va plus
les non seulement gelé voter mais j'ai
fait partie de celles qui défendent est
et de celles et ceux qui défendent est
la mise en place de fiches et parce
qu'effectivement le traçage et le
contact font partie de la vdl de la
prévention contre la propagation du coc
u19 mais je crois qu'on a ce qu'il nous
faut avec 7,7 ce système qui est un
système contrôlé qui est entre lehmann
d'assurance maladie qui avec kate qui
est contrôlé par des médecins et qui est
un système d'un travail au public
là on nous propose une application qui
est une application facultative dans un
certain nombre de pays où elle a été
développée des poules elle n'a pas
produit d'effet les gens n'en parlons
pas à quoi télécharger donc le
gouvernement est un des instruments
parmi d'autres mangent et le sentiment
tda
engagé sentiment que le gouvernement je
ne défends je sais pas s'il faut dire le
gouvernement dans cette affaire où le
secrétaire d'état chargé du numérique
voilà cedrico qui en a fait une
obsession est un sujet très personnel
car envie d'avoir une technologie est de
porter une nouvelle technologie de
philippe l'a rejoint quand même il a dit
c'est un outil extrêmement puissant
cette semaine il a enjoint tous les
français à télécharger l'application des
trucs gouvernement je ne ferai pas par
exemple vous n'allez moi j'ai chargé
cette appli qui se trouve ça
superfétatoire par rapport au système
centralisé qu'on a mis en place il ya
moins de 15 jours
et puis par ailleurs à un moment donné
on peut se poser aussi l'action de
savoir jusqu'à quel point on veut tout
le temps être avec le bluetooth les
données et toutes nos données stockées
et je pense qu'on est tous d'accord pour
dire que le système qu'on a mis en place
est bien celui là est une une espèce de
marotte technologique d'un gouvernement
qui veut absolument montrer qu'il est
très performant sur le plan humain que
vous avez un téléphone portable que vous
utilisez google ou amazon qui ont
énormément de données sur vous sur votre
consommation sur votre façon de vivre
finalement est-ce que ça va tellement
plus loin est ce que c'est tellement
plus liberticide que sega femmes
mais la question c'est que c'est celle
de l'efficacité si on mène mais si on
admet l'idée que lors que dès lors
qu'une personne ait diagnostiqué
qu'ovide elle est prise en charge par le
système de recueil des données sous
l'autorité d'assurance maladie qu'est ce
que ce système là va donner de plus et
qu'on va on va savoir qu'on a été dans
une rame de métro ou dans un train avec
quelqu'un qui à l'aube ou du
compartiment ensuite un même des clients
aux principes
meetic a été neuf tickets coville ceci
me paraît être une marotte technologique
beaucoup plus qu'une décision sanitaire
damien abad est certainement d'accord
avec vous il juge que ce top cow vide
c'est un écran de fumée face aux
défaillances de l'état sur les tests de
masque on l'a entendue dans le reportage
à l'instant est ce que ça donne le ton
des commissions d'enquêté parlementaires
écoutez je ne sais pas ce qui se passera
à l'assemblée nationale sur les
commissions d'enquêté assemblée
nationale dès lors qu'elle vise
l'exercice du pouvoir par le
gouvernement sont toujours un peu
particulière pour dire les choses en
soutenant la ferme de la commune enquête
pénale a
au sénat je sais que nous allons
travailler sérieusement notre but n'est
pas la mise en accusation des uns et des
autres notre but c'est de comprendre
comment l'état a pu être aussi peu
préparée dans un certain nombre de
domaines en particulier les masques puis
des tests
comment l'état a pu nous raconter dans
un premier temps que les masques ne
servait à rien puis après qui servait
que à ce qu'avait que vit depuis en fin
de compte qui servait peut-être à tout
le monde et puis que maintenant on
pourra peut-être en avoir comme voilà
donc toutes ses responsabilités
partagées avec les exécutifs précédent
est ce que vous allez remonter pour vous
est il nécessaire par exemple auditionné
à marisol touraine explique je pense que
tout ce qu'on était en charge de
l'hôpital public est en charge des
politiques publiques de santé au cours
des dix dernières années auront des
choses à dire devant la commission
denquête ça me paraît normal on voyait
on voit bien mal de l'auditionner
les masques les masques sont un sujet
mais il n'ya pas que les masques il ya
le nombre de lits de réanimation dans
l'hôpital public le ratio entre le
nombre d'habitants le nombre de lits
l'état de piraterie de lumière à faire
agnès buzyn vous devez l'entendre
rapidement dans cette commission
denquête coûté la gamme ou syndicats
devaient se mettre en place au mois de
juin on va la laisser faire sa campagne
municipale à paris et je pense que
d'après les minimales ya pas eu
organismes le sipal mellal m dit elle
même qu'elle avait hâte d'être
auditionné pour faire la lumière sur son
sur son rôle c'est formidable et lads de
tous d'être auditionné d'être en
campagne
bref vous l'entendrez donc après le 28
juin où poursuit cette émission avec le
projet portant sur diverses mesures
urgentes pour faire face aux
conséquences de l'épidémie qu'ovide 19
[Musique]
ce texte qui porte diverses dispositions
urgentes est un assemblage hétéroclite à
un de mesures pour faire face à
l'épidémie comme aubrac cite par exemple
un projet de loi très critiqué par les
sénateurs car il a bu selon des
ordonnances aux rêves états les
sénateurs ont trouvé un surnom à ce
texte
certains ont même dit il s'agissait d'un
projet gloubiboulga difficile selon eux
de déceler un fil conducteur tente ils
brassent de sujets pêle-mêle
l'allongement du délai dit vg pendant
l'état d'urgence l'indemnisation des
victimes d'essais nucléaires ou les
règles du chômage partiel
c'est ce périmètre ministériel sont
concernés le texte du gouvernement
prévoyait aussi 40 demandes pour
légiférer par ordonnance sur ces sujets
très différents
c'est une procédure exceptionnelle qui
permet de prendre une mesure sans débat
parlementaire
en pleine crise 57 ordonnance ont été
acceptés 40 de plus ce serait beaucoup
trop pour les deux chambres
nous ne devons pas faire perdurer cette
pratique initial justifiée par la
situation mais qui aujourd'hui ne l'est
plus des semaines après un début de la
crise petit à petit un phénomène
d'accoutumance à la marginalisation du
parlement s'installe or comme le temps
le parlement est malmené c'est la
démocratie qui fabienne après lecture
des deux chambres le texte n'autorise
plus qu'une petite dizaine d'heures
donnant pour le parlement la crise ne
permet pas tout en matière de justice
notamment le sénat l'a rappelé hier
concernant un amendement du gouvernement
il visait à étendre les cours
criminelles un dispositif testé depuis
moins d'un an avec des cours d'assises
sans jurés populaires nous avons besoin
de ce dispositif pour faire face dans
certains départements aux difficultés
qu'ont vont rencontrer les cours
d'assises dans le contexte de la reprise
d'activité liée au kobe 19 réponse des
sénateurs vaut profiter de la situation
pour opérer un bouleversement de notre
système judiciaire
quel que soit notre désir d'être utile à
la résolution des problèmes
d'encombrement de la justice nous ne
pouvons pas accepter cette évolution
l'amendement a été rejeté le sénat
demande un vrai débat une fois
l'expérimentation terminée
rappelé en filigrane l'importance du
temps long
laurence rossignol est ce que ce projet
de loi était nécessaire pour différer
différentes dispositions techniques
pendant l'état d'urgence
probablement quelques unes étaient
nécessaires je pense par exemple à la
prolongation de l'expérimentation sur
les maisons de naissance qui allait
s'éteindre fin novembre et on avait
besoin de légiférer
le gouvernement a amendé la loi
précédente et a prolongé d'un an ça
c'était nécessaire mais plus plus
largement qu'est-ce-qui observant ce qui
se passe depuis le début d'état
d'urgence le gouvernement vient au
parlement que pour des mesures d'urgence
et à chaque fois pour demander au
parlement de se dessaisir de ses
compétences et pour donner au
gouvernement la possibilité et le droit
de légiférer à la pince à la place du
parlement
mais ça c'est vu qu'il avait décidé dans
l'état d'urgence sanitaire de donner
plus de pouvoir à chaque fois le
gouvernement vient demander de nouvelles
habitations
on peut considérer que certaines étaient
utiles comme par exemple pour mettre en
place des dispositions sur les limites à
la liberté d aller et venir pour un
certain nombre de mesures de départ mais
après en quoi est il utile aujourd'hui
de réorganiser aussi bien la justice les
finances les rapports avec par grévin
article 3 ans n'est du tout voire danse
et alors l'abus de pouvoir supposerait
que ce ne soit pas légal mais c'est un
exercice maximum de ce que la loi permet
mais surtout l ennemi n'est possible que
si le parlement est d'accord pour se
dessaisir de son pouvoir de légiférer
or le sénat qui quand même depuis 2010
est en charge quasiment seule la
question de la vie parlementaire
la question démocratique la question du
respect du parlement le sénat en charge
sa seule puisque l'assemblée nationale
est composée d'une majorité qui était
jusqu'à présent extrêmement vaste
extrêmement docile à l'égard du
gouvernement et qu'il n'était pas
préoccupé parce que peut-être manque
d'expérience manque de compréhension de
la nature de nos institutions et du rôle
du parlement dans la démocratie
l'assemblée nationale se dessaisit très
facilement en fait la majorité en marche
donne très facilement gouvernement ses
compétences
donc c'est le sénat qui est chargé de
veiller à l'équilibré des pouvoirs et
c'est le sénat qu'il fait une fois de
plus dans ce texte
avec à la fois la majorité de droite
mais aussi la gauche au sénat et à la
semblait en disant stop les flatulences
si vous voulez légiférer vous venez avec
vos textes
il ya une réduction du nombre des
ordonnances à l'assemblée et au sénat
l'assemblée a aussi agi sur ce sujet oui
mais en face le sénat a quand même
considérablement restreint le nombre de
10 la délimitation est ce qu'un membre
d'habilitation parce qu'elle des sujets
le gouvernement on peut on peut siéger
on vit comme si on ne pouvait pas siéger
mais on peut siéger sur d'autres textes
que les lois d'urgence ou desproges loi
de finances rectificative années que ça
laisse des marques que ça marginalise le
parlement cette période je crains que de
la part d'un gouvernement que je juge
déjà que je qualifie déjà comme étant un
gouvernement peu enclin à faire vivre le
parlement peu enclin à défendre et
respecter l'équilibré des pouvoirs et
très enclin à gouverner seul sans le
parlement je crains que la période est
et année là un effet d'aubaine on nous a
parlé l'autre jour d'effets d'aubaine
à propos du thym d'un amendement sur les
frais bancaires ou le gouvernement
addiction limiter les frais bancaires
savait faire un effet d'aubaine pour les
familles fragiles on a là je veux que le
parlement pouvaient légiférer vite et
bien vous savez habilité le gouvernement
à prendre des ordonnances ce n'est pas
l'image irait bien c'est géré vite et on
a effectivement légiférer aussi vite
oui et non parce qu'on a quand même
travaillé sur chacune de 5 une des
dispositions qui nous étaient soumises
mais nous aspirons nous parlement a
retrouvé nos compétences et notre
travail habituel
un mot sur le rejet de justesse d'un
amendement que vous avez porté plusieurs
fois depuis le début du confinement pour
l'allongement temporaire du délai d' ivg
de douze à quatorze semaines une fois de
plus cela n'est pas passé au sénat cette
semaine
oui parce qu'on sait que le confinement
l'état d'urgence la désorganisation des
hôpitaux et la concentration du travail
sur les cadres elle sur la réanimation a
eu un effet délétère sur l'accès aux ivg
et puis j'ajoute quand même con on a
tous constaté et la presse a été très
très très bon relais dans cette affaire
que les violences conjugales avait
beaucoup augmenté pendant la période de
confinement et je rappelle toujours que
dans violences conjugales il n'ya
violent et que l'augmentation dès
violences conjugales peut
malheureusement aussi conduire à une
augmentation des grossesses mandé
et les médecins et nous ont alertés très
vite en nous disant on a un problème
avec les délais dit vg qui sont trop
courts par rapport d'abord aux femmes
qui étaient déjà hors délai au moment du
confinement des 13 mars et qui devait
partir à l'étranger qui n'ont pas pu
partir à l'étranger
les jeunes femmes c'est pas si simple de
quitter la maison avec son autorisation
en dix ans alors ça a été rejetée hier
pourquoi la droite conservatrice
finalement je vais venir
c'est pas si simple donc le sujet était
réel les médecins le disent et le
planning familial le dit aussi
et le gouvernement c'est a été
obstinément but et est hostile à cet
allongement des délais à chaque fois
qu'on en a parlé à javron les alerter
ils ont dit non on reste dans les délais
qui est tel qu'ils sont pour les délais
légaux dvg et ils ont trouvé hier au
sénat avec l'aide la plus conservatrice
du sénat un excellent partenaire pour
rejeter cet amendement qui pourtant a eu
beaucoup plus de voix qu'il n'en avait
eu des fois précédentes donc il nous en
faudrait y revenir une quatrième fois
peut-être pour avoir la majorité
mais je désespère de convaincre ce
gouvernement qui je le rappelle avait
raconté qu'ils aient des femmes la
grande cause du quinquennat mais qui
quand il est face à un vrai sujet sur la
détresse des femmes est incapable de
prendre la décision qu'il faut prendre
et préfère s'allier avec les
conservateurs elle est laurence
rossignol dernier thème de cette
émission les dons de congé pour les
soignants
[Musique]
une initiative parlementaire pour aider
les soignants en première ligne dans la
crise du coronavirus le député la
république en marche christophe blanchet
propose de pouvoir donner des congés ou
des rtt à convertir en chèques vacances
au personnel de l'hôpital pour améliorer
leurs vacances et bien la proposition de
loi adoptée en commission sera débattu
mardi prochain dans l'hémicycle de
l'assemblée nationale
elsa monde à gaza après les
applaudissements tous les soirs à 20h
comment prolonger cette reconnaissance
de la nation aux personnels soignants
pourquoi ne pas permettre aux français
de leur donner des rtt ou des jours de
repos transformer en chèques vacances
j'ai la solution retenue qui consiste à
convertir les jours de repos donnait en
chaque vacances permet d'apporter un
soutien visible aux soignants qui
pourront davantage profiter sur leur
temps libre
le loisir supplémentaires musée par
l'attraction voyages restaurants
théâtres un loisir supplémentaires dans
une des 200 milles structure en france
dédié au tourisme et à la culture qui
accepte les chèques vacances
pour la députée en soumises caroline
fiat par ailleurs aide soignante
c'est à l'état de se montrer plus
généreux on va demander aux employés
libre-service ans va demander au facteur
en bas demandent aux éboueurs
on va demander aux mamans et qui te
faisait du télétravail de de faire
d'aussi sal ethan mettre en place ces
aides
côté républicain on s'agace surtout de
s'être fait voler l'idée fin mars le
député maximino proposait déjà
d'autoriser le don de congés bref je
veux parler ici de la méthode
une méthode qui constitue une faute
déontologique majeure consistant à
reprendre une proposition de
l'opposition ligne aurait volontairement
et sans attribuer les mérites la
majorité se défend d'avoir plagié
maximino voulait donner des airs tu
étais là il s'agit de les transformer en
chèques vacances
la proposition de loi a été adopté en
commission elle sera débattu dans
l'hémicycle mardi prochain
laurence rossignol est ce que vous êtes
favorable à cette initiative écoutez je
ne sais pas s'il va venir au sénat c'est
une proposition voix de l'assemblée
et moi je suis favorable à tout ce qui
permet aux français de manifester leur
générosité
bien entendu mais je suis comme un peu
gêné par cette proposition de loi
d'abord il ya quand même l'idée que les
rtt en aurait trop et je ne peux pas
empêcher de penser que les mêmes qui
porte cette proposition de loi
aujourd'hui les nerfs ou une partie de
sedan marche sont ceux qui ne manque
jamais de nous rappeler que les 35
heures sont un boulet dans l'économie
française et que les français ont trop
de vacances trop de congés trop de rtt
et donc la guider c'est que mon rétro de
rtt donc on les donnerais première
remarque donc j'ai un peu perplexe sur
sur le fond qui existe déjà pour des
salariés d'une même entreprise
le mécanisme existe mais dans un cas
très particulier c'est des salariés
d'une entreprise quand et un d'entre eux
qu'à un enfant très malade et qui doit
s'absenter pour accompagner un enfant
malade
par ailleurs je pense que la générosité
elle doit être incarné humainement ce
n'est pas simplement faire un chèque
et là c'est faire un chèque vacances et
moi je pense qu'il faut aussi favoriser
la générosité la solidarité qui se
manifeste d'être humain à être humain
donc je trouve que cette proposition de
loi est probablement belle proposition
d'affichage je crois que les soignants
ont besoin d'argent ils en auront avec
ces chèques vacances probablement mais
quand même l'équipe qui a des rtt
aujourd'hui les salariés des classes
moyennes ils payent des impôts
souvent ils trouvent même qu'ils en
payent beaucoup des impôts nos impôts
servent à financer notre système de
santé payé correctement les soignants et
leur donner leurs rtt et leurs congés
bien mérités à la fin de tout ça bref
enfin en conclusion je n'applaudis pas
dès demain parce qu'en plus je pense
qu'à la fin du confinement
tout ceux qui sont restés à la maison ou
qui ont été travaillés auront le droit
de reposer ses cales et assurer et
prendre et c'est toujours l'idée
derrière qu'on a trop de rtt c'est pas
vrai et en tout cas et c'est sûrement
pas vrai pour les femmes qui ont été
doublement ou triplement mise à
contribution pendant la période qui
vient de s'écouler comme elles le sont
d'ailleurs toute l'année alors avant de
se quitter
laurence rossignol nous voulions rendre
un hommage à claude goasguen député les
républicains de paris est décédé ce
jeudi
un arrêt cardiaque après avoir contracté
le kovy de 19 il avait 75 ans chiraquien
convaincu c'était une figure de la
droite et du parlement députés pendant
plus de 20 ans claude goasguen à
l'assemblée c'était un polémiste
invétéré au verbe haut et au fort
tempérament libéral assumé il s'était
investi avec conviction dans la lutte
contre l'antisémitisme
voilà pour cette émission merci laurence
rossignol merci beaucoup le rend très
fier d'avoir participé à cette émission
pas de petit mot sur claude goasguen
non mais surtout chez moi j'ai jamais
été élu de paris donc j'ai pas ces
génies député claude goasguen
mais ce que je trouve qu'on vit une
période où tous les jours beaucoup
d'entre nous pleurs quelqu'un voilà hier
beaucoup et au gaz guen on a tous pleuré
enfin moi ce qui me concerne guy bedos
on a perdu nos henri weber l'ancien
sénateur député européen jean loup
dabadie et je trouve que depuis deux
mois
ce qu vide plus âge on a beaucoup
beaucoup de tristesse qui nous entoure
et le bilan humain et affectif de cette
période ce sera douloureux pour beaucoup
il entraîne ou le remercie beaucoup et
avec laurence rossignol on se retrouve
la semaine prochaine pour un nouveau
numéro
mais par les moyens tôt
[Musique]
pas du tout